hi everyone I'm in the UK at a pmics
conference dealing with Islam and I met
my friend John here who's an ex-muslim
but I have to ask how can you
be how could you have been a Muslim your
name is John well I am now follower of
the Lord Jesus Christ and when I became
Christian I um I read the Gospel of John
and I I was in love with how the John
the the Gospel of John said in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
God and the word became flesh and I
choose to become John new God New Faith
new life with the Lord Jesus Christ and
so you're from Yemen why don't you go
ahead and why don't you just go ahead
and uh tell us how you uh ended up
leaving Islam and uh becoming a
Christian so I grew up in Yemen into a
Muslim family uh into a devoted to
Muslim family and my family taught me
how to pray how to fast how to read
Quran and 2014 14 I want to I was
doubtful about Islam because I felt
there is no spiritual connection between
me and God the Creator and this is we I
ended up to go to Mecca I was the
luckiest one to go to Mecca the house of
Allah and in Mecca I was going around
the block the house of Allah and I I
realized this is human being made this
is not from God and there in front of
Kaa I rejected Islam I give up Islam in
front of Caba and that was very hard
wait just to be clear you became an
apostate from Islam in front of the
cabba in front of Caba in in the front
of the most holy place of Islam the
capital of Islam wow so uh so uh what
what happened after that after that I
was agnostic for three years it was the
most hardest life in my the most hardest
three years in my life because in Islam
as you said if you are apostate if you
denied Islam if you rejected Islam there
is a Hadith whoever Chang his religion
should be killed so I have to be secret
for 3 years it was very hard then I um I
left Y and I met Christians and they Tau
me about Jesus Christ and I start to
read the the gospel of Matthew and the
the teaching of Jesus Christ the
ceremony in the mount and that changed
my life upside down I said this is the
god I'm looking for this is the god who
died for me and rose again he's alive he
loved me so much that he died on the
cross and rose again so I give my life
to Jesus Christ I become new a new
creation new believer and this is why I
chose that I become John and now God
called me to sh to share my faith with
with the whole Nations and with my
people with yemenis because I always
declare Yemen for Christ oh they really
need it down there of course they need
the Lord Jes really need it down there
yeah they need the Lord Jesus Christ
everybody need the everyone everyone
need need the Lord Jesus Christ
absolutely so how can people uh follow
your work so my name is John ranim on an
Instagram they call me Tik toer John um
uh on Tik Tok Facebook uh YouTube John
ranim and I will put the links to all
those in the description box thanks
brother thank you so much it's an honor
to meet you and you are one of the U
cafir one of the most uh infidels in the
world against Islam the kafer
king God bless you thank you
[Music]